well it's an annual tradition for us
isn't it to where either ours or if
you're youssef
your girlfriend's christmas jumper so
pre-roll we had to
adjust the neckline because i looked
like a christmas steve jobs
he looked like a festive steve didn't
you i suppose the second lesson is like
test something's worth by taking it away
for a while and see if you notice
anything or see what changes
try not doing something that you think
is helping and see if you're right or
not
if you're right great like try not
sleeping for a month i guarantee you
conclude
that sleeping is helpful we've seen a
massive impact on people's mental health
this year and a lot of it i think stems
from people not
being comfortable in their own company
it's actually really dangerous
having a poo in a hospital toilet
because the emergency buzzer is next to
the toilet roll and it's a long cable
and it's really sensitive
i've pulled stuff like that before in
the past i've i've yanked a red
cord like that before in a steam room
thinking that it was the
like the thing for more steam this is
the more steam chord
ladies and gentlemen mary krembo
look at us look at how lovely we are
look at this
get you get your christmas jumpers out
for the lads
so nice you always have the classiest
christmas jumpers
johnny look at that it's so abercrombie
isn't it
johnny duped us last year with the
um the light up one it's broken
you said it was voice activated i think
yeah
so what where's that from is it
hollister so this
so the reason i'm wearing this is that
becca has bought
all three of us all three of us
including dexter matching christmas
jumpers
so dexter has the same jumper slightly
smaller obviously
and then becca also has one and they're
the same
but kind of slightly different color
themes but i agree like it's very
like you could wear it you could wear it
out and just have your hand sort of the
reindeer the armor over the reindeer and
no one would say anything pretty trendy
like oh johnny johnny's wearing
one of the jumpers he always wears well
it's an annual tradition for us isn't
it to where either ours or if you're
youssef
your girlfriend's christmas jumper
so pre-roll we had to adjust the
neckline because i looked like a
christmas steve jobs you look like a
festive steve didn't you
no festive steve's come to join us uh so
it is
christmas end of the year we usually do
a little bit of a wrap-up a couple of
things that we've experienced a couple
of lessons couple of fails
and we might have time for a quick game
of bear or bull
at the end as well what are you doing
there no this is no he's warming the
potatoes
chris warming potato yeah
can you throw it to me youssef can you
throw it to me
chris will have a potato in the pan it's
golden it is warm
it is really warm johnny i know you've
got a drink in your hand by catch
thank you there you go right first
lesson from this year
blobson for me okay um
so that i think
in obviously i feel like we need to
comment on the fact that it's been a
strange year
as in like a lot of people have had a
very different life this year to normal
and i think the what that's encouraged
me to do
is i think i entered the year and you
two probably remember this
like i was constantly adding things to
my
life like i bought um i was doing like
cold showers breathing reading jumping
on a trampoline doing skipping going for
walks doing runways
and i basically just stopped almost all
of that
um so just trying to yusuf and i've
spoken a lot this year about
80 the 80 20 principle and i feel like
that's the sort of thing that i
like think about a lot but never
actually practice so i've just tried
this year
and i've been trying every every area of
my life to
um try and do that get the same
by doing fewer things or even try and do
more or improve by doing fewer things
across everything so like closing the
wardrobe
apps on your phone like everything that
you like regularly do think what what
could i do just make this like simpler
and easier for myself and i think all
that's
basically like from the from january
2020 johnny to december 2020 johnny
i just do fewer things and just have
more like
bandwidth that's how it feels but i've
not known what's a morning look like now
then because you were doing all this
stuff jumping on a trampoline in a cold
shower and a walk in a wrong mode and
reading and meditation as well probably
what's morning now yeah so i just
meditate
nothing else but for longer
i think this is a great lesson
because we're we're so wired to
look for more stuff more books to read
more ideas to take on more methods more
programs whatever it is that someone's
going after
and really that's never the limiting
factor in 2020.
squeezing the lemon of what we already
have has so much
mileage but people are like oh no that's
boring i'm just gonna
look for the next thing i think it's
just that like self-improvement
is very additive by nature like a lot of
people look as like what's the
you know i'm i'm trying to improve
myself but i still feel
anxiety or i still feel like i'm not
improving
i need to add something else like maybe
i suppose if you're doing absolutely
nothing to improve yourself but that
probably is the answer but i think
a lot of people listening to this
podcast are probably doing lots of
different things
and i'm not saying you should do fewer
things but i think the
the 80 20 thing so we've done a lot of
that in in business this year and you do
find that 80 of the progress comes from
20 of the things
80 like 20 percent of the or like 80 80
percent of the problems come from come
from 20
of the things as well so it's like if
you just consistently streamline
streamline
i think it's just a happier way of
living your life if you
obviously you can cut out too many
things and slow down
there's a potential that you might have
gone too far with that like just
meditation means you're not reading
consistently
it means that you're not doing any
breath work
because we know that if you miss the
beauty of a morning routine is that it
kind of
locks in a ton of habits early in the
day
and ensures that you get them done
that's the best for me the
best hack about having a morning routine
is it certifies that you do
things that you need to get done every
day
i suppose the question is why are you
doing the things
i think that's what i've spent a lot of
time thinking about like why am i doing
wim hof why am i doing why am i having a
cold shower why am i doing like what
there's a
it's like you're trying to do something
you're trying to like achieve something
or change something with all of it and i
think the
um the thing that i noticed from
so i suppose the second lesson is like
test test something's worth by taking it
away for a while and see if you notice
anything or see what changes
because again it's very different
they're very difficult if you have a
morning routine you have lots of habits
lots of things you do
just adding things in and you don't know
really
whether it's the thing that you started
a year ago that have been doing every
day or whether it's the thing you added
last month that's having the
change so if you stop doing something
it's like ah
i took that away like i took rumwad away
for example
and my injury rate was the same i hate
that
the delayed reaction to stopping
something and not noticing the decline
or the improvement
for three months and then you're like
what was it
yeah and it's not i don't think it's the
case that like these things do nothing
it's just that there's always a
trade-off between
like i could do fewer things and achieve
largely the same result
and surely that's better just from a
like the number of things you have to
manage perspective
um but it's probably just it'll be like
a you know in a year's time i'll
probably have added 10 things and again
right it's just a phase that i'm going
through but i think it's been very
helpful this year
because it's just a lot it's allowed for
a simple
structure versus like this time last
year i felt like
there was so many things that i was
trying to do
um to basically just like
feel better we know that at the start of
this year
all of us were super super impressed
with how much you'd added in and
you were crushing it with this really
great routine so that took quite a bit
of agency
and some you know there's a lot of
inertia to get over when adding in even
one thing let alone a whole ton of
things
and then yeah to be able to let go of
the tether to that balloon
of i've built up this pattern finally
i've actually managed to achieve it
and to then be able to have sufficient
agency to to drop that
is like maybe even harder so i think
that that kind of identifies why he's a
bit of a [ __ ] man
like it's just so it is it's the same as
it's the same as whenever you
hear george mack talk about something
you're just like [ __ ] hell like this
guy just
doesn't really seem to deal with
obstacles
in the negative ways just happy to see
like input process
output here's a way around it and that's
like i think definitely something you
can be proud of this year man like to
let go of those tethers on a year where
we're all being neurotic as [ __ ]
um i think yeah that that that's awesome
i would i will be interested to see
where it goes and i think you're right
as well
we keep on bringing it up that is it i
always get this wrong
seth is it goethe that talks about the
vacillation between extremes of
societies
uh is it height or hegel hey i think
you've confused me now
oh sorry i've got it wrong i [ __ ] you
know about 20 times but yeah we we do
vacillate between these things right we
go from like minimalist to abundance we
go from
excess cerebral to excess mindful to
excess physical whatever it might be
um and then eventually at the age of 65
you'll have finally sorted your morning
routine uh yeah
the age of 65 just wake up and read the
paper
don't you like it's always you've
completed it at all you're just like
what's the point of really any of that
[Laughter]
[ __ ] stupid um man that's that's
really awesome i'm really happy for you
this year
with regards to that thanks i think
the lesson for people is like try not
doing something that you think is
helping
and see if you're right or not if you're
right great
like try not sleeping for a month i
guarantee you conclude
that sleeping is helpful so
it's a great way to test the hypothesis
isn't it i don't think sleep really
matters right
fine all right what's that what's that
diet where you
would take out tons of stuff with
inflammation in and then add them back
in one by one
that's the elimination diet yes
basically a
personal development routine equivalent
of that right
see that would be really useful because
then it sifts all of the
marketing claims and people selling
their
six digit journal and the eight
eight minute booklet in their five
minutes
filofax and all this stuff
it's five minute firefight that's a good
one i'd buy that
we'd all the problem is that we would
all buy it if the five-minute filofax
came out we'd all buy it because we'd
think it would be the answer
you'd buy it for me and i i'm not going
to use my table yeah
and you'd eventually like read through
it like
[Laughter]
right scobe what about you lessons
lesson number one from 2020
this is more of a vicarious lesson i've
seen it in other people because
i've got to admit this year for me has
been
barely any change to my lifestyle um and
i think for all three of us just because
we're all anti-social bastards um and
the work we do
either involves being at home anyway or
in my case being in a hospital which
hasn't
changed but we've seen a massive impact
on people's mental health this year and
a lot of it
i think stems from in fact hang on
i don't want to downplay the massive
impact of people losing their jobs and
um being alienated from the families and
stuff and that that's huge and that's
circumstantial unavoidable but the other
side of it
is people not being comfortable in
their own company
and if you this is kind of highlighted
it where you put someone
as johnny said if you you put someone on
their own for some time and they very
quickly learn
how much they like themselves how much
they can say in their own company
this is my lesson number two oh no
that's all right that's okay
unbelievable that that's
that would land on that but i suppose
well there we go i can give you that one
i've got we can just come back you can
just combine it together right you can
if you've both converged on this same
thing i think it's probably a pretty big
lesson
fair enough yeah no stooges you use
there's no trickery this isn't like
we it's darren brown
you're seeing this reel unfold live
so one of the things that gary webber
points out is that
oh no you can see johnny's reaction if
you're listening
is that the the worst the highest grade
punishment you can give someone
at least in a civilized world is
solitary confinement
and johnny's really upset
the second highest punishment is taking
the hot potato
taking somebody else's lesson of 2020
and stealing it without them knowing
uh yeah so gary weber says being on your
own
solitary confinement is one of the worst
things you can do because
suddenly someone has no distractions
available to them they have to
face the crap that they've kind of
tucked away
all their life and it's just sat there
and
so the lesson is to to learn to make
peace with that so
it's not a not a quick process there's
no hack it's just
a very long-term habit of
taking the tissues out of the tissue box
and until the tissue box is empty
just to be fully clear on that there's
no that that's a that's an analogy right
you know actually
emptying the tissue box and then putting
them back in again and then emptying the
tissue box you can have loads of
listeners that just go out and buy
bulk kleenex right am i going to be
happy yet so what's the lesson from that
the we need to learn to cultivate
the ability to be comfortable in our
with ourselves in our own company
and a lot of people have learned to do
this
this year anyway it's just accelerated
it's catalyzed that process
um but it's so it's been so interesting
to see that
unfold you got anything to add there
blob so the the there's a study that
gary weber references
um about yeah i think we might we might
even talk about this so before we came
on this podcast i checked
the life hacks list and i don't think
any of us have actually ever said
meditation i think we've mentioned abs
we've said yeah different particular
ways there's like four
four or five apps or what like things to
try
but the the hack that we've not actually
suggested people do regularly is
meditation
but the the study that gary references
is
they took i think initially university
students and put them in a room
and they had to sit by themselves for 15
minutes and it was
like they found that and so they weren't
like any devices they were not to check
anything
and it was incredibly painful for people
so they gave people
a bracelet that was attached to a like a
strap around their ankle with the option
to shock themselves with electric
electricity and over half of the men i
think
opted to shock themselves
just like when you think about that
it is insane that someone would rather
shock themselves with electricity and
then sit by themselves for 15 minutes
and that'd be amazing it's
such a like 14 year old or like year 9
activity as well like you sat there
you've got like a bit of deodorant you
just spray it until you're like
yeah or doing that thing with a compass
where you go like d
d yeah like through your hand
well you have the two-man version where
you flick pennies at each other across
the across the desk oh yeah and then
when you do it you gotta hit your
knuckles
so i i think um who's the person who
said all of man's problems stem from the
fact he can't sit in a room
uh quietly by himself i think that's a
philosophy it's either goethe
hey probably probably hagel uh but i'm
pretty certain that's
thousands and thousands of years old and
part of me wants to blame hyper stimulus
and
the modern era of devices for ramping
our dopamine up that we can't sit in a
room on our own
but it seems like that's the sort of
thing that's been around for quite a
while
i reckon it's worse in this decade than
it was
yeah um do you remember if
15 years ago you could like you'd turn
up for an appointment for something
and you'd sit in the waiting room and
you would just be like
if someone doesn't like they're a
psychopath so i really hope that ben
harrison is listening to this but if he
does that whenever you meet ben
and he's there before you and you see
him like through the window he's just
sat like this
just understand about it you know in a
holding pattern
and you look at me like ben that's weird
mate you can't like i know it's all
about my phone
yeah it's weird you've got to stop doing
it
well the number one thing that phones
have achieved is they've eliminated
boredom
like nobody is bored anymore nobody ever
as long as you've got battery nobody's
bored anymore
um and it's a combination of
habitual checking in terms of it's
actually drilled into your synapses that
you go into the pocket you get the phone
out which is why a great life hack for
anyone
that wants to reduce their phone time
the simplest one you can do just keep
your phone in the different pocket
so swap the pockets that you have your
phone and your wallet in and the number
of times that you'll take your wallet
out
and look at your wallet and you're like
oh
went to egypt and he was driving this
this banger and it was obviously
left hand drive he kept
banging his hand off the um off the wall
off the door phone oh right okay
yeah um and also every time he went over
a speed bump the airport would deploy
every time it only happens once
yeah you don't like every time right but
yeah
he said it was quite sore wow i can
imagine
did he shout into me and to me
uh any any other sort of insights around
that
surf about the solitude
not from the solitude one i've got
another one
coming up which uh which may be
related but so just to wrap that one up
and yourself so someone's heard all of
that
and they think yeah i agree like i've
had a lot of this year like sat in a
room
like bored by the tv sat with my
thoughts
what what say like right in 2021
i'm gonna try and do something about it
i'm going to
uh yeah so usually if someone hasn't
got a handle on this it's because
they're just holding it just at bay like
just to arm's length the whole time
and the counter-intuitive thing is just
to let it in
just to do something that does involve
total solitude with you know as chris
said put your phone in the other pocket
or leave it at home go for a walk like
do something that
really forces you to to do that and
if you can do something that's full
solitude for an extended amount of time
many bouts of solitude become much
easier to handle
and eventually become actively
pleasurable
until as cheesy as it sounds if you can
become your own best friend
then you're just having a great time
aren't you
i think this year's definitely
highlighted how much people's lives were
held up by the scaffolding of not being
on their own
like fortunately i put this in a
newsletter a couple of weeks
ago introverts have had a competitive
advantage in 2020 for the first time in
history
like almost every extrovert outperforms
an introvert because they can network
harder they can spend more time around
others
it's kind of what is seen as a
more uh admirable more desirable trait
in
other people because it makes them more
personable and you can just spend more
time around other people so your
networking effect multiplies
but this year that's been stopped so
it's very much been
are you able to recharge your batteries
on your own the problem that i see
that links in with phone use is that
people have got a confused definition of
solitude cal newport's got the most
useful definition of solitude that i've
ever seen
which is time away from the input of
other minds
now that's not driving in the car with
the radio on calling a friend every
so often on a long journey that's not
being in
your living room watching netflix whilst
double screening on your phone
like that that's that's the opposite
that's more input from other minds
like genuine solitude is something that
you can learn from but hiding from that
fact
pushing it away repudiating it by giving
yourself this false sense of
socialization
means that you're not getting the social
contact that you desperately desire
but you're also not learning the lesson
about solitude and being comfortable
with yourself
so certainly progressive overload in
terms of that even if you can just do it
30 minutes at a time
one hour at a time 90 minutes at a time
you know like extending that
there's a really good i think that
that's a really good heuristic for
what is actual solitude because yeah if
you're just sat
calling mates and watching stuff or
whatever then yeah it's not
really solitude it's just um
diluted contact with other people and
i did a video on nofap recently which is
an internet movement of people that
refrain from jerking the gherkin
um so that they can improve their
dopamine sensitivity
and and they're claiming all these kind
of huge benefits that um
that they get psychologically and
physiologically and i was saying in the
video that
a lot of the big benefits people get are
because they're going from a
pathological state to a normal state and
that's what's
causing this this big change in the most
people probably
wouldn't get such a big improvement from
it something i do think people will all
get a big improvement from and that's
because we're all pathological with it
is this idea you said of like double
screening
and like even when even netflix alone
something that's designed for
like compulsive retention is not enough
to trigger all those
dopamine receptors so you have to then
get a second screen out like
we are mental and so
i think doing that repeatedly makes us
so desensitized to dopamine
simplifying but to to the reward
circuitry
that when we're just with another person
that's not
enough it doesn't doesn't scratch that
itch
and so we end up then having to like be
with another person but also on our
phones and i think
people of our age like we recognize it's
rude and so we don't do it
but when you see like teenagers together
like you know when you know
every city especially like cities like
newcastle liverpool
leeds that have like a casper's ice
cream
shop that's like a next to next to
it's always outside of a place called
the green isn't it
yeah exactly and there's like pink neons
black leather sofas and like
30 flavors of ice cream you all you see
like groups of
18 year old kids all sat like in silence
on their phones yeah like wow
well the the mad thing at the beginning
of this year which i said in
the first covid episode that we did was
i took a like
undue amount of pleasure from other
people struggling with the challenge of
working from home
like i was like welcome to the [ __ ]
party welcome to this and then i
realized after a little bit of time that
that was
my own projection like i shouldn't take
pleasure in other people
entering my nightmare like that's not a
thing
um but that's what i was doing um
and after a little bit of time i
realized right okay no be a bit more
[ __ ]
noble and virtuous than that but very
much so like this is this is a pill
that we all had to swallow a long time
ago and maybe there might be some other
entrepreneurs or
sort of working from homers who have
felt this for a long time and then this
year it was like
like put me in coach like this is my
time
and yeah it's been an interesting year
of reflection definitely people becoming
more comfortable in solitude
it should have expedited it because you
haven't had any choice like you've had
to do it and for a lot of people
that's probably something that they can
take away yeah there's been a lot of
negatives that have come about this year
but you've learned to be on your own
like that's definitely one positive i
think you can take
what's your lesson from this year chris
how are you
uh first one is the power of rest
so classic type a personality do more
get more done um even though i took the
essentialism red pill this year
and decided to do less in terms of
breadth
that gave me more capacity to do more in
terms of depth
so the total amount of time that i spent
working wasn't reduced it was just the
number of projects that i worked on
that was constrained heavily by the fact
that my main business
events had stopped but that just gave me
even more time
to work on doing whatever it was that i
[ __ ] did um
i put this again in a newsletter a
couple of weeks ago the trip to dubai
gave me such an unbelievable sense of
perspective
it was nothing as lovely as dubai is
nothing special about dubai
but it was about the fact that i had
this
change in working routine in a year
where everybody has
felt like it's groundhog day over and
over again you're looking at the same
four walls you get up there's
you haven't got five weddings to go to
you haven't got a barbecue you haven't
got somebody's birthday
there's nothing there's there's no i
haven't even been ill
this year because i haven't seen anyone
i haven't got i haven't got sick
because like who the [ __ ] going to
infect me like we're hiding from a
pandemic
so upon going away it reminded me of
something i learned from ali alton who
was in the sas
and
either like fought or snook their way
through and then they'll get outside
they'll take a moment to just reset
breathe slow down a little bit consider
what the objectives are
and then they'll go and that period of
calm between two periods of intense
chaos was what i termed a personal break
point
it's called a break point in the special
forces and i termed it a personal break
point for me while i was in dubai
and it just forced me to come back and i
think this links in with what you were
saying johnny about
kind of really giving a first principles
look at your routines
and thinking like okay is this serving
me does this actually make my life any
better or am i just doing it because
i've always done it
even if it was once good like we can
talk about kind of the first
level like basic [ __ ] make you drink
three times a week because your mates do
but then even taking that into something
which has been
the horse of troy snook in by
uh it being something that was good once
breath work did serve me
at one time cold showers did serve me at
one time getting up at 5 30 a.m every
day and going for a walk did serve me at
one time
but does it now my requirements are
different my routine is different my
life is different and then
you know that consistent checking of
whether the things that you are doing
serve you
can only be facilitated when you've had
a break from it because it permits you
to have that perspective and clarity
around things
and very much i came back and it was the
happiest i've been at home in
maybe even years uh that's amazing yeah
it was it was it was
unbelievable man i obviously was super
inquisitive about like
what the [ __ ] going on that i've come
back from a place that was 32 degrees
every day of glorious sunshine to
somewhere where i can't leave the house
and it's got about eight hours of
daylight
most of which is grey like why why am i
so happy being back home
and i i honestly think it was because i
got to see a life that i've crafted for
myself with new eyes
and think very much it was well timed as
well going into a new year
to think about okay what do i want to
try and achieve next year
but from first principles not just what
do i want to carry over that i'm already
doing or do something i already do a
little bit better
like genuinely what do i want to do and
it gave me this kind of
yeah a very um liberated sense of
bottomless potential for next year
so have a break micro and macro
yeah it comes into what you said about i
said last year on this
uh 2019 podcast
of chris sparks idea of nothing gets
grandfathered in
everything is up for sale just because
you've been doing something whether you
think it's
good or think it's bad it has to get
re-examined and say right
should i continue this habit or this
project or whatever
yeah did you find that you got
the same amount of work done in dubai
like did you still get the like the key
work done in spite of like
i presume working fewer hours um the key
work yes
i i can't pretend that i was working on
the
probably the long term important on the
cusp of important but not urgent
because inevitably there are some things
that will take you away from that
there's a boat party on tonight there's
a mk's playing at a pool
there's whatever's happening we're going
out for dinner i'm going for a walk i'm
cycling in the desert
um but the stuff that keeps everything
ticking over i kept on top of
perfectly fine and had i have been there
for longer
and it not had a defined endpoint that
we pushed back by a week
but i had a defined endpoint to it um
perhaps i would have
forced myself to do that stuff but for
instance the next lead magnet that i
want to do for the newsletter is 151
books to read before you die
like i was not going to start that
project while i was out there it's got
no defined
deadline to it it's it's slightly
confusing and messy to begin there's a
lot of inertia to get over there was no
way i was going to begin that while i
was out there
but i kept recording i kept on a
recording schedule uh i kept meditating
while i was out there
i kept on doing my rehab for my achilles
all that stuff
i think the this is something that i've
i've found like not necessarily this
year but like on
in years where you're traveling going
like three weddings in a week
um sometimes the most for us like we'll
have like
the most profitable week ever in in
propane and i've worked some of the
fewest hours
and you look at it and you're like [ __ ]
sake you know like all these weeks where
i sit and like
hammer away at the trying to push the
boulder up the hill when
there's just a rate that it's going to
move and no matter how hard you push
is a nice reminder to say like actually
i can just take
i can't just stop working have to have
the rest of the day off or i can take
the weekend and not check my emails or
whatever
um but i think that's harder and harder
to do when
there's fewer so the average person at
home this year hasn't had the
what the [ __ ] else is there to do the
the desert to go and cycle
yeah or the beach party to go to um but
yeah i think it's a
i think a lot of people i know have have
just let work like
fill everything because it's either work
or netflix sleep work netflix sleep
i think it's about matching the
personality type of the person
to the recommendation which you kind of
had tipped to before which is that
if you're a taipei hard driving
over-achieving personality
then you need to engineer in work into
your day
whereas if you naturally gravitate to
sloth then you need to create structure
to do the work um interestingly someone
called
neve who listens to the modern wisdom
podcast and got in touch with me
as a result asked me to do a talk at my
hospital
um for junior pharmacists and junior
doctors
on like life hacks four it was two
clinical life hacks
and one of them was
go for a poo so bear with me
it's but when when you're on a an
on-call shift which is where you are
covering
the entire hospital out of hours for 13
hours
um it's a long shift and it's basically
your your adrenal glands are just slowly
getting nipple crippled for the whole
13 hours so you're getting a phone call
every like 30 to
30 to 60 seconds and you've been asked
to do those stuff and you're just
getting like
slammed kind of relentlessly and
if you just go from one job to the next
without that personal break point
you just you your cortisol is just going
to go
so you you do just have to stop and have
a poo and be like you know what
i'm allowed to poo like what if you
don't need one
even if you don't need one you can just
just sit and have a have a shampoo you
know how you have
the sham surgery with stu mcgill yeah do
the same thing so you prep as if you're
going for a poo
pound you go into the cubicle do you
have to wait
that's a good question if you want me to
believe it
if you want me to believe your shampoo
was a real poo shampoo
it should be a shampoo shampoo
it's actually really dangerous having a
poo in a hospital toilet because
the emergency buzzer is next to
the toilet roll and it's a it's a long
cable and it's really sensitive
i've pulled stuff like that before in
the past and then like the security come
bursting
when you're in anaphylaxis i've
i've yanked a red cord like that before
in a steam room thinking that it was the
like the thing for more steam this is a
more steam chord
and a woman with like a like a box
run into the steam defibrillator it was
just like i think a box of like
miscellaneous
like blasters yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm not gonna bandage you passed out
you're gonna put a plaster on my
shoulder
yeah so yeah that was um basically
working more can deliver less output as
well is kind of a subset of that
that it it's the sort of thing that you
hear everybody say but you're like yeah
yeah yeah but that's for people who
don't don't actually know what they're
talking about
like no no no it's not just diminishing
returns that you get from work you
genuinely can do work which is
so bad or move so slowly that across a
week you will deliver
less output by working more if you
decide to
undersleep yourself over caffeinate
yourself create work
which is motivationally
so subpar that it makes you feel bad
the next day you don't want to do work
honestly just having some sort of rule i
know that
like a hard stop can often be difficult
because the stop can come at a time
which is
awkward within the workflow especially
if you finally found focus after
fighting to to get a hold of it for the
last few hours
um but finding a point and saying right
okay like that's enough for today like
congratulations well done
and then giving yourself genuine rest
time away from that
the david allen quote your ability to
deploy power is directly proportional to
your ability to relax
that's a that's not a power lifter
that's a man who does productivity for a
living
um so yeah that that i guess you're
totally right that's the micro and the
macro
i definitely think that a personal break
point as a prescription needs to be
longer than a week
i don't think that you can get the
benefits from a personal break point
by doing a holiday which has no
resemblance to your normal life
or a trip away which is
just work in a new place that's exactly
the same the whole the whole point is
that everything changes except for the
core elements of your life
and that actually goes back to what you
said johnny where you were like did you
get work done
across the board and i didn't but i got
the skeleton done
which is what is the the minimum viable
product it's like that what i have to do
each week
which meant that everything else was up
for sale in the
uh chris sparks example like nothing
gets grandfathered in
except for obviously the stuff that
needs to be grandfathered in like
obviously i need to eat obviously i'm
going to train obviously i'm going to do
you know the projects that actually
matter to me well you have to do those
things but
the way that you eat or the way that you
train is up for sale
right johnny next next your second
lesson has been popped doesn't it yeah
well my my second lesson was just um
meditation which is a really simple one
let's just i was saying it isn't in life
acts list
um i think was yousef to put me onto it
originally
and then you put me in touch chris with
a brian meditation teacher
yeah um and like even the um
so i suppose all of what was saying like
the sitting alone thing and the
even like knowing when to take a rest
and all these sorts of things it just
it just comes back to like awareness of
yourself awareness of how you feel
everyone gets to sort of towards the end
of the day and thinks i'm not getting
anything done now
but i'm still gonna like sit here and
just like hit my head off a laptop and
hope that yeah
hope that something comes of it yeah um
but having like a formal practice like
that
i think is just the best way to get
better at that
like when do i need to stop when am i
feeling anxious what is feeling anxious
like
i don't have to identify with being
anxious just because i have this
sensation and just having a practice
like that that becomes like a really
i think i've taken that a lot more
seriously this year
where i've previously done like 10
minutes here 15 minutes there was now
it's like the first thing i do
just because i do i think it's like
having a good night's sleep you know
you wake up having having had a really
good night's sleep and you just
you compared to any other day it's not
even close in terms of
like the decisions you make the way that
you feel i think after doing a long
meditation session i feel the same way
which is a recent thing
didn't used to happen like that so i
think it's just a compounding hundreds
of hours
situation what's your current practice
i'm going to guess that you're following
brian's fight well it's
shinzen young's five ways to know
yourself through brian
it sounds like such a
five ways to know yourself through brian
yeah like uh the meditation accelerator
like get to know yourself for five ways
by brian yeah
um so it's a bit of that it's a bit i've
been following um
so this is this is taken from ben again
who's mr meditation
who i know has recommended this to me
and you said there's a film called
chasing the present where this guy
interviews like
um so i mean gary webb is the the big
name in the uh og
in the in the film but a lot of his
stuff like the self inquiry stuff i've
been doing so he's got some guided
sessions online
some of the shinzonian stuff like the
noting practice
like is it visual or somatic or audible
um just that really um but i think the
thing
i i spend too much too long getting
caught up in like the method
or like program hopping and not enough
time in just doing i need to just do
30 minutes a day like i just need to do
enough time
for this to actually make a difference
um i think hearing
gary say it needs to be like a minimum
35 minutes
is a real like
like it's not very 10 10 minutes for 10
days headspace is it he basically says
like you're wasting your time if you're
doing less than 35 minutes you're just
like oh gary
gary we've all got real lives leave me
alone mate yeah
stop making me anxious um but yeah i
think he's done like 20 000
hours or something of mindfulness
practice
but now just has no has no thoughts yeah
he's the guy that switched off his
default mode network isn't he
this is what i love about gary weber
because he
fully puts his money where his mouth is
like he's been a researcher and
participant
in a lot of the harvard functional
neuroimaging studies where
he's just like yeah put me through an
fmri and
his brain just does not work like other
people's brains
do you think i think i like any activity
what do you think about this about
having no thoughts
he's like i say most of the time because
it sounds more believable and like when
i'm tired and
and stuff like they do occasionally come
back but most of the time
like you can use thoughts for problem
solving and things like that but there's
no like blah
blah blah blah blah going on constantly
i just love how he admits that like
if he's feeling a bit groggy he
occasionally has a thought
[Laughter]
most people when they're feeling a bit
tired of just drowning in
and he has the occasional like that's
not going to work
all right oh that's [ __ ] oh this is
going to go badly
when my blood sugar is a bit low
they can occasionally re-emerge so i
think like
the chasing the present film is a guy
who had
or has like material success he just
outwardly is it is your average
like millennial i suppose
who has all these things go well for him
and then realizes like hold on
i still feel terrible like i still worry
all the time i still
don't feel at ease with myself so he
goes on this huge journey
and interviews loads of like big names
in in uh the meditation world
really good film so if anyone wants like
where is it amazing
ben sent it to me on youtube pro or
youtube
paid for whatever that's called but i'm
sure it must be on amazon it must be
elsewhere as well um yeah so
that's not really a life hack but i just
noticed that meditation is not in the
life hacks guide
there's just loads of ways to try it
well that says it all that it's such a
taken like what you're not meditating
every day
what's wrong with you um yusuf it was
yusuf who said to me
in liverpool i forgot after we got out a
lift and said
like stop being a dick about it and just
do 30 minutes a day for 10 days and
you tell me that you don't feel any
different
it it's because johnny was was following
like the atomic habits method
of like starting at two minutes building
up to four minutes a day and
three minutes three three then four
sorry um
and i think for a lot of habits it that
can work um
but i think when a habit has a minimum
effect of dose like meditation
it could be counter it could be
counterproductive because you're then
doing all of the
the boring bit without the the benefit
yeah do you
do you believe yourself and i will move
on after this because i'm aware i've
spoken about meditation a lot but do you
believe that 30 minutes
like the gary weber thing of if you're
doing 15 it's literally pointless
i don't think it's literally pointless
but it so gary's
purpose of meditation is to quiet the
mind enough
to do the self-inquiry and fully uproot
the the illusion of self
that's the so so the meditation's almost
a means to an end for him
i see um whereas you will still get the
benefit of time and detention with
meditation
from doing small amounts of it but i
also think it's
so i i don't think it's as much of like
a there's a switch
but it's like um training
if someone says someone's doing six
minutes of training a day they'll get
maybe a bit of benefit if that training
is like super dialed in and
absolutely perfect and really consistent
but it's kind of
making it difficult for themselves
compared to the guy who trains an hour
three times a week
and goes deep with it what if the six
minutes is just burpees
that's what i mean yeah if it's like do
you mean are you saying because it's
like
no no i was just i just whenever i think
of like how would i make training as
hard as possible for
i think there was a crossfit open
workout or there was a crossfit workout
which was just
seven seven minutes of birthdays yeah i
can think of i can honestly think of
nothing worse
training-wise that's as bad as it gets
yeah lesson two
scope lesson two
is that 2020 has been the year of the
confidently wrong
so this is basically from
all of the kind of online health experts
and so on just coming out of the
woodwork
and praying on people's
health anxiety or fears um
not helped by media and so on that's
that's basically been like
scaremongering the whole time and
selectively using
um claims or stats to like really send
the shits up people to keep them in the
house
which which like you know it has a it
has a policy purpose but
there are um there's definitely people
that have tried to capitalize on that
and they're either knowingly wrong
or they're unknowingly wrong and so this
is like
people selling immune boosting
supplements online or
um like we once saw someone selling an
anti-cancer
diet and you know all this kind of thing
and you're seeing people repeatedly make
predictions about
what's going to happen in the next month
and then they might even be
high-profile people that are then shown
to be like dramatically wrong
and the lesson really is to hold your
opinions lightly
i think this is a lesson that i've
internalized quite a lot um and i think
it's been
caused by having my anus handed to me
a few years ago from big trading losses
and that's because trading is the
abstracted version of this
like yes you're just looking at a line
on a screen
but that that's like the perfect way to
distill that down to the pure
emotional rawness of being wrong because
you can
invest all your ego into like oh no it's
definitely going to go up now like after
and then you you like you go sunk cost
fallacy and you invest you like
your your energy into it and you're like
oh no but it's definitely exactly you
seeing patterns that aren't really there
and then the market just keeps hitting
you with pain until you learn the lesson
and so by doing that you end up
realizing actually
i have to hold my opinions lightly not
you know just for the sake of keeping my
ego in check but because
i'm going to be hit with pain if i don't
so i think it was it was a great teacher
and it applies to everything else that
if you're able to quickly change your um
opinion on something based on new
evidence
then you're never going to be stuck in a
losing position i think the problem
is especially with social media
certainty
is conflated with truthfulness or
expertise
yeah so someone that's absolutely hard
in the paint about one particular point
i i keep using this example but it was
just so [ __ ] flagrant i couldn't
believe it
joe biden said at the beginning of this
year that stopping chinese people coming
into the country was xenophobic
and then two and a half months later
said that the travel restrictions were
entered too late
it's like dude you do not get to [ __ ]
do that
you don't get to do that like you're
supposed to be
the vanguard of statement like
truthfulness and honesty and the problem
is that
i i don't know why perhaps the media
teams say actually mate if you were to
track back on that
and identify that you were wrong it
shows in the polls that people are going
to lose faith in you or something like
that but
that that's only if you're so basic that
you can only hold
one thought in your time in your mind at
a time like if your
mental ram is so constricted that like a
goldfish you can only remember the last
thing that this person said
and not frame it against the things that
they said before but
perhaps this is me being a [ __ ]
perhaps a
reputation on the inter the internet is
additive with a time limit rather than
multiplicative
across time i don't know additive with a
time limit rather than
multiplicative so imagine if you
multiplied by zero
you'd end up with a big fat zero if you
say something which is just totally
totally wrong
and then decide to multiply it by
something else which is totally wrong
you're just at zero
whereas what it might be is it's just
zero plus zero plus zero plus one
you're like oh look at me i'm at a one
and everyone's forgotten all of the
[ __ ] zeros in any case
oh i see yeah so so i think the the the
memory span of the feed and all of that
stuff is very short
yes you'll get the occasional person be
like oh but you said back in march this
and but also that the whole system as
you said the polls and the algorithms
and everything are all
they don't reward nuance and restraints
which is what every true expert has
because they're they realize how little
they know and they're like well
you know it could be okay but um and
they reward people who are
certain and promote um
outrage in the comments and yeah the
media thing's a big one like i was um
in the hospital the other day one of the
staff was like yeah doctor are you
having the corvid vaccine i was like
well maybe but um
most likely yes but you know i don't
want to be one of the first guinea pigs
but
she was like i saw her on facebook they
gave it a bunch of african kids and
al died okay
where did you see that it was on
facebook i'll dd like
okay i mean there's some degree of
nuance between those two opinions
yeah i didn't even know what to say
about him and it like makes me
viscerally uncomfortable
like the level of like especially
facebook this year
that the nail in the coffin of facebook
has been covered 2020.
it's just a cesspool of people who
haven't got remember when everyone was
adamant
that the army was being deployed to
london to lock people in their houses do
you remember that
when people were sharing oh well uh my
my cousin
is uh actually is part of the reserve
armed guard for the 14th northumberland
division
uh and and he sent and it was like
forwarded through like a million
whatsapp groups
you're like what is this it's like a guy
wearing his
kit walking down a street it's not the
the
yeah martial law's not being [ __ ]
deployed
so this this is funny because people
believe that more than they believe the
immediate
stuff because a friend of a friend is
like like my brother is still convinced
that um doctors are shills putting um
putting covert on death certificates of
people that didn't have it and
to bump up the numbers and i said to him
like
you realize i i work in a covert
hospital
and i've not put that on a death
certificate
for like seven or eight months and he
was like
oh yeah but that's because you're too
junior like it's the seniors that are
getting paid after it you're like
no because it just do it and also i wish
i was being paid off by
big pharmacist how [ __ ] orchestrated
would this
uh conspiracy have to be how many people
would they need to keep quiet
about this the thing is like i i'm not
being paid anywhere near enough i would
love to
to have a little science side pack from
not really it's the same thing as like
when darren brown's like i don't use
stooges
and people like oh he definitely uses
stooges like the the tightness of his
network
for him to use stooges and not one of
them just go to the daily mail and go
i'm a darren brown stooge
and that's darren brown so then think
like imagine
all of the healthcare system in the
world is in on this huge
thing the number of people that have to
be sufficiently paid off to not one of
them
just go to the media and go here's all
the evidence or tell their wife
yeah or do i want it is me being told to
do this they'd get a big old payout
wouldn't they yeah
it's unless darren brown threatened
their family
but but this is what i mean individually
this yeah so that's like the
lengths you'd have to go to to get to
get everybody on board
and that's just darren brown i mean
he'll just use mike magic
is there a is is there a heuristic that
you use for people online
scope obviously like you've identified
this problem which is people being
confidently wrong
um certainly jordan peterson
in one of the interviews with where he
it wasn't with kathy newman it was when
they sent kathy newman away put her on
like a really big course of steroids and
got to do 531 and she came back with
like research and a new haircut
and she worked for gq i remember that um
it was like ah you idiot you haven't
seen my final form
and then he basically said um if i can
take one of your opinions and from that
one opinion
predict everything else that you believe
there's something very very wrong here
because you shouldn't take your opinions
wholesale they should be piecemeal
so that's an identifier that i would use
look is this person
just basic [ __ ] 101 conspiracy
left right with absolutely no nuance but
that's difficult to tell online
like what what do you use a really good
um way of looking at it that
that the world is not doesn't fit into
one ideology or category so if someone
only has opinions that have that flavor
there's a big red flag there isn't there
um
and so because it shows that they
haven't thought of themselves they've
just taken it
so yeah my the way i filter that is um
for example i i was like i'm supposed to
be
a representative for healthcare and
i don't really know much about the
vaccine so i need to look at
some of the data so i'll never i'll just
never go to anything
that sniffs of social media i just have
to look at the original sources
um i just don't think that any of the
filtered dance stuff that's getting to
social media is ever going to be
accurate or well obviously there's this
stopped clock is right twice a day but
try and find that in social media
is so hard um there was a good podcast
for
the layman if anyone's interested in
kind of understanding this stuff
with peter ratia and a guy who is
on the board for the fda approval of
vaccines um
with like and this is his his special
area and he's worked in drug approval
and everything
and he talks through in a very
systematic way
um some of the mechanisms and processes
there so
i would go to things like that it's a
lot of work that's the problem
it's significantly easier to read a
tweet take it as true
and then start broadcasting it to
everybody else or retweet it or tell
tell your parents going and doing
research and actually having to think
for yourself is hard which is why most
people
this is a really good video from people
going with this guy going around like a
trump rally
and he's asking people they've all got
the hats on and stuff and he's like
so um what do you think of the
allegations about trump's thingy and the
transcript and they're like
think for yourself read the transcript
so i gotta say
and then oh have you read the transcript
no i i haven't got time
for that kind of thing okay how long did
you wait in the queue to get to this
protest and like seven hours ah seven
hours okay
a lot of free time okay but think for
yourself yeah and read the transcript
that's funny yeah
you've not read the transcript no no
cool
we are running up against my time a
little bit guys sadly
well i'm gonna have to do my second
lesson and uh we'll finish it there uh
we were going to play a little game of
bear or bull but
we'll save that for next year if you do
have any bears or bulls basically topics
that you want to hear whether or not
we're bearish or bullish i.e negative or
positive about and why
uh just send them to me or put them in
the comments and
we will be doing an episode next year so
my final one
was a lesson i learned i guess from my
injury which is you're more resilient
than you know
and i think this probably actually
extrapolates out across a lot of people
this year
um you know sadly there's going to be
some people who were with us at the
beginning of 2020 who aren't going to be
with us in 2021
uh because of the pandemic and the same
goes for businesses the same goes for
relationships and financial investments
and
bank accounts and all the rest of it but
for the people who are still here and
are listening to this
you're still here like all of the things
that you thought this year that were
going to absolutely annihilate your life
all of the worries you had that didn't
come to fruition or did come to fruition
but didn't end up finishing your world
like you are still here and
that was kind of brought front and
center for me when i ruptured my
achilles i presumed that my constitution
as someone who's
had depression in the past and sometimes
just has catastrophic thoughts
i just thought i'm going to deal so
badly
with this this is going to be it's just
going to set in motion
a downstream [ __ ] like a nightmare
and what ended up happening was yeah it
was uncomfortable and there was a couple
of periods of like
just sheer suffering when i was dealing
with stomach cramps
from opiate constipation for three days
solid unable to sleep eat
go to the bathroom and doing all of that
with one leg
was like a particular low light but
all of those things that i went through
very quickly just reset
my expectations and with sufficient
stoicism and a little bit of mindfulness
i actually found like so much more
fortitude in myself that i didn't even
know existed
and that's kind of put a lot of faith in
me for what i might be like moving
forward
because i genuinely opened the door
inside of myself in a house i've lived
in my entire life to a room that i
didn't know existed
and i was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] like
where's this fortitude and resilience
come from
and it was just like when it was called
when it was required
it came type thing um and that
ties in nicely with realizing just how
little of our own internal motivations
and
the fact that our consciousness gets to
see this tiny tiny tiny little blinkered
sliver
of what our true motivations are and
what we're actually able to be aware of
is so much less than the elephant that
was sat on the back of from a mental
perspective
and yeah realizing that all tied
together for me to think like
stop being so cerebral about things you
can't be a reductionist utilitarian
about
absolutely every different potential
permutation that's going to occur in
life you are far more resilient than you
know and
if you need it it will be there and
because of that
the person that you are now when you're
worrying and the person that you are
if the incident that you're worrying
about occurs are essentially totally
different
have faith that the future you is going
to be able to deal with whatever's going
to come
have faith at the future you will pay
the bill make the business work regain
the client
fix the relationship get over the
relationship fix the achilles
deal with the opiate constipation
whatever it might be
like all of those things came together
to make me sort of really reassured
that everybody's constitution is far
stronger than than they know
and specifically mine and i'm like a
really really good example of somebody
who i think
who i thought would be terrible in that
sort of a situation and i managed to get
through it so yeah that was um
you are more resilient than you know
nice yeah that is
very good i like the idea of discovering
a room in your house
that you didn't know was there
i just hope i don't do my achilles i
wouldn't advise it i mean
as a personal development strategy it
was effective but
not necessary like i wish that i hadn't
had to do it to realize it but
you know in terms of you've done a sharm
achilles that would have been better
like you're still white
yeah but you've still got to worry
gentlemen i
i really appreciate it it's been a year
where we've probably not seen each other
probably the least we've seen each other
in in forever and maybe even spoken as
well
which is a shame but hopefully hopefully
next year that'll change
and uh i value both of your friendships
i value the fact that you're both in my
life
uh as i always do uh propanefitness.com
modern wisdom to find out the seven
things you won't believe about how to
build an online business
and propanefitness.com calculator if you
want to get your macros sorted
did i get it right you did yeah you
could even just go to propane
fitness.com
oh okay that don't be easier don't do
that
chris it's been a pleasure it has yeah
thanks for having us back on man
we're gonna do it more we just need i
need to get a hold of you guys it's
significantly easier when we
can sit down in the living room because
we can get multiple episodes out
i can't wait until we can do that again
i know man i got my i got my
um couch like re upholstered as well
yeah yeah it's so much more comfortable
it was all flaccid before and now it's
very turgid
it's just ready like beckoning us to
and yeah look gents thank you uh have a
good christmas and to everybody that is
listening merry christmas as well
uh i will see you in a couple of days
actually chris sparks coming on
to talk about how to do the ultimate end
of year review
uh so it's a very timely episode so stay
tuned for that one as
we've already said all the stuff from
propane fitness if you're an online
coach go and check them out
and they will teach you how to
transition online or to improve your
online business as it is
for now gents merry christmas see ya
[Music]